you'll also find this difficult in terms
of the bats of it but like the actual
earth particular number you'll have to
do but it's a new kind of idea so the
head is approximated Bruce now by Avenue
into this is this question you are asked
to solve this question in one of your
exercises of radians now I am in fact
not going to solve it right now if you
looked at this in strung with a
particular last clock which made you
just sort of we did it sideways and I
don't even know what is that okay then
tell me how will happily come help you
later on but I just want to point out
that this equation at least did the
tools that we have developed over the
last eleven twelve he is this equation
cannot be solved exactly you just cannot
do it 1 minus 1/2 X does it makes this
algebra right as this trig function they
just started we don't have any tools
that we can use to arrive and exact
precise solution you're kind of stuck
now the funny thing is for many years
you've been solving equations but we
have very deliberately hand keep all the
ones that nice isn't do it then there's
a three step approach or formula but we
have artfully dodged all the these
acquaintances the kinds of equations of
the populate all of real life when you
just can't simply sold you can't find an
exact value or you can do you say look I
can get something this close you know
what in real life sometimes that's all
you need if I can get in the right
ballpark I can get to a design level
accuracy that's all I need right it's
really just about positions were kind of
like we put it to be exact the real one
if you're an engineer or if you just
like I need this experiment as close as
possible you just need to be roughly in
the right wall
so I'm not going to solve this one
because it actually ends up being a
little bit messy why won't you pick a
simple one here's the question I want to
toast underneath this the question is
what is the decimal value
of the square root of three what is the
decimal value of the square root of
three
now we of course can reach to our
calculators and just get a number
immediately and fairly painlessly but
that that raises the question like the
calculator can do that because we
trained it to do that how did it know
how to do that right
what's the persistent point actually
getting an RT we are going to find the
decimal value through three at least
we're gonna get pretty close now I think
we all know there's three three as a
number less root 3 has a number it has
to be somewhere between well if I can
pick some like hold on this whole
numbers that I go okay um the nearest
square number 33 is one right that's the
closest square number close to less than
three and the closest squared oh that's
bigger than three is home so clearly we
three must be somewhere between these
two numbers do you agree with that
should that means it's between one and
two okay so I know I've got to be in
there but that's a really big range how
do I get any closer right we're gonna
learn two methods for doing this the
first method is quiet it's kind of a
brute-force method but it's actually
quite simple and elegant so I'm gonna
show it to you the subheading is
bisection method
this is the name I give it weight and
yes we're gonna solve this so this is
just by example because you've been
looking with this question recently it
just exemplifies the fact that you know
what sometimes you just can't solve you
just kind of do anything to it right
this is another easy so this is called a
bisection it is not the name probably
that you're here most often most often
you hear it called having the interval
but because it mathematics we have a
single word that means how many visible
namely bisection I kind of and you guys
have heard of bisecting things before I
see the reason not to use it I always
want to use less words rather so that
was funnier than I thought okay here's
what I'm going to do I need you to take
this and I'm going to take advantage of
all the things I know about corner
geometry it's all gonna phrase this as a
function okay now root three I think we
all agree root 3 is a solution where is
a solution
to an equation right what's in the
solution to the equation of what will be
a simple equation where one of the
solutions is your dream okay I could go
to a country go to treat that would be
fine like I know treatments kind of in
applies a little bit but I'm gonna go
like even easier than that how about x
squared equals three like that will do
it okay
that's a nice easy function to do it I
don't have to appeal to trigonometry
which is learned all the problems okay
so this equation Richter is one of the
solutions obviously thinking through
three is the other one so I'm going to
phrase this in language that will help
me solve it hopefully a constant rather
x squared equals 3 and x squared minus 3
equals 0 same equation but the whole
point of phrasing it like this is that
what I'm trying to find is a word to
this equation if you agree with that
like I'm trying to find a placement that
equals 0 that's exactly what we defined
prints to be okay at both of these
methods bisection method and the other
one you'll learn which is going in there
been finding these roots finding when
you hit zero so let's let
f of X equal x squared
now one of the reasons why I chose this
function at about 10:00 is because X
minus 3 in fact every polynomial is a
continuous function there have been
breaks no cheeks of the in the whole
type of right draw right we want one
smooth line okay so being it's a
continuous function and it's zero at
some set point that means that on the
left of that I'm going to be one side
positive or negative and on the right of
that I should change sign do you agree
with that that's the only way you can
pass through zero
you've got to change side does that make
sense so what I'm going to look for is a
change in sign let me show you how works
with these guys if I got this is f of X
what's everyone
it's one nice three Naidu - okay what
about F of - what now you may be there
one right 4 take away 3 that's 1 do you
see it as a change in sign right I have
to change sign between 1 & 2 or rather
from 1 to 2 because somewhere in the
middle I'm gonna get a zero so I haven't
drawn myself a ridiculously large set of
axes over here and I'm very country to
do the same
you can see how but wanted to hear
because now I had a couple of values
youth now let me emphasize to you after
this first time I'm not going to expect
you're ever going to draw a diagram to
demonstrate this ever again but you need
to see what is happening and you
particularly to understand why this
works and why it's called bisection so
for everyone here's my f of X axis
against my x axis
everyone is getting negative 2 so I'm
just going to draw that as the Wallace
put it I possibly can on my scale so if
I put it down here F of 1 that makes
this negative 2 that means negative ones
about it
so there's a point that half of X passes
through the other point that I have F of
two is going to be well I want it to be
roughly the same distance something like
that so it's not here there's efforts to
and you can see I've negative before a
positive after just somewhere between
I'm gonna slice through the access and
get this rip it off done make sense